drama vor der küste australiens ein
schnorchler ist im bundesstaat victoria
im süden des kontinents allem anschein
nach von einem hai getötet worden
dankend crowe war gerade einmal 32 jahre
alt es wäre sein 33 geburtstag gewesen
den wollte er mit seiner familie beim
campen in der gegend von port mcdonnell
feiern
wir haben heute morgen einige
gegenstände im wasser gefunden die uns
dazu bringen dass wir diesen vorfall als
einen haiangriff behandeln wie sie
hinter mir sehen können machen wir im
rahmen der ermittlungen im moment
tauchgänge in der region
es geht noch ein paar stellen die wir
nun untersuchen möchten aber aufgrund
von informationen von experten sieht es
so aus dass die suchaktion verkleinert
wird
und das leider zu einer angelegenheit
für einen bericht der gerichtsmedizin
wird
zurück bleibt nun danken cross
jugendliebe und ehefrau und sein kleiner
sohn levi die familie hat sich in einem
statement an die öffentlichkeit gewandt
sie schreibt dass die genauen umstände
von duncan zu verschwinden noch nicht
geklärt sind aber spuren und einem
gefundenen neoprenanzug auf einen
einschließen lassen
zudem soll in der gegend zuvor ein
weißer hai gesehen worden sein
vor australiens küsten gibt es offenbar
immer mehr haiangriffe 2020 töteten die
großen raubfischen dort so viele
menschen wie seit jahrzehnten nicht mehr
acht todesopfern zählten die behörden
dort im vergangenen jahr
zum vergleich im durchschnitt der
vergangenen 50 jahre gab es dort pro
jahr nur einen tödlichen angriff 2009 10
sogar überhaupt keinen christian kemper
ist praktisch wenn man im eigenen haus
die besten experten h du hast drei
bücher geschrieben über haie kennst dich
mit heim wirklich aus wie kaum ein
anderer jemand auch mal kurz auf diesen
aktuellen fall ein warum in dieser
gegend ist das da besonders typisch dass
dort diese haie eben leben und auch dass
es dort immer wieder zu attacken kommt
ja in der tat die südküste für
australien ist bekannt dass ich da viele
weiße haie aufhalten
ein paar hundert kilometer weiter
östlich liegen die berüchtigten kangaroo
island da gab es erst im dezember einen
schweren angriff
online surfer von einem weißen hai der
surfer hat gerade eben überlebt noch ein
paar kilometer weiter sind die neptun
islands die bekannt dafür sind dass man
eben käfig tauchen mit weißen haien
machen kann
das ist jetzt zwar 400 kilometer weiter
östlich aber studien haben gezeigt dass
weiße haie bei gemächlichem schwimmen
tempo 80 kilometer am tag zurücklegen
können das heißt das ist also ein klacks
für weiße haie diese distanz zu
überbrücken und haie machen ja nichts
anderes außer sich von temperaturen
leiten zu lassen von meeresströmungen
schwimmende küste auf und ab auf der
suche nach beute
und was kann ich da machen wenn ich als
schwimmer oder auch surfer unterwegs bin
worauf muss ich achten wie kann ich mich
richtig verhalten
nun man sollte nicht in den frühen
morgenstunden oder in der dämmerung ins
wasser gehen was hier in diesem fall in
port macdonald ja leider passiert ist
der angriff ist um 17 uhr passiert also
es war schon leichter dämmerzustand weil
das eben die jagdzeit der haie ist aber
was noch viel wichtiger ist er war
leider alleine am schnürchen und das
sollte man niemals machen auch als
taucher wird dann beigebracht ging
niemals alleine tauchen das zählt
natürlich auch für schnorchler oder
surfer einmal wenn etwas passiert wenn
ich angegriffen werde ist niemand da dem
ich retten kann
ein dave berry ein freund der könnte
mich am strand schleppen könnte erste
hilfe machen könnte notarzt anrufen das
habe ich alles nicht wenn ich allein ins
wasser gehen
und wenn man als sportler oder taucher
mit einem zusammen
schmeichelt oder unter wasser ist bildet
man halt ein größeres gebilde und das
schreckt den hai erst mal ab weil der
hai sich nur ein großes objekt und nicht
zwei nicht zwei taucher sondern ein
großes objekt unterhält erstmal distanz
wenn man allein im wasser ist ist der hr
geneigt mal anzukommen und die das
objekt zu untersuchen
im kart schon bilder gesehen können die
gleich nochmal zeigen die nicht nur
faszinierende aufnahmen von haien sind
sondern die dicht zeigen dort tauchen so
ganz genau mit heim
das war ein guadalupe oder lupe ist eine
kleiner
insel vorgelagert von mexiko im pazifik
und da bin ich dann eben mit weißen
haien auch außerhalb des käfigs getaucht
uns jetzt so entspannt hier ja mit
weißen haien getaucht sagen ja irgendwas
gefährliches erlebt ja doch also zwei
situationen waren gefährlich weil in
einem punkt waren vier weiße haie
gleichzeitig um mich drum herum und man
vergisst immer wenn man im wasser ist
hat man ja an dreidimensionalen raum
unter sich man guckt nicht immer nur ist
daheim ist daheim sondern können auch
von oben und von unten kommen und das
war eben so eine situation als ich dann
nach unten blickte und von unten kam ein
großer weißer hai auf mich zu und ich
dachte was machst du jetzt weg da macht
man in so einer situation wegschwimmen
hatte keine macht keinen großen sinn
weil die haie sind wir sehr viel
schneller ich habe noch kurz überlegt ob
ich mich waagerecht ins wasser legen und
dann dachte ich dann kann der heimlich
wenn er will
umso einfacher packen im endeffekt stand
ich da schwebte im wasser und hat nichts
gemacht und mein herz schlug immer höher
und so ungefähr einen kilometer vor
flossen kontakt drehte der weiße hai
dann doch ab und weil das einfach nur
glück oder warum glaubst du als fachmann
warum hat sich der hai dann anders
entschieden
ich glaube er wollte einfach testen was
ich bin und wie ich reagiere wenn ich
wirklich panisch weggestorben wäre dann
hätte das sicherlich so ein trigger
ausgelöst und er hätte vielleicht ein
angriff gestartet
dadurch dass ich aber ruhig geblieben
bin ich wollte einfach nur mal checken
was bin ich ist neugierig geworden
wollte mich so ein bisschen austesten
was trägst du am hals das sieht auch aus
wie ein teil von einem hai genau dreimal
rausholen zahlen aus einem weißen hai
allerdings versteinert die findet man
die werden teilweise angespült an den
stränden und ja da dürfte schon paar
millionen jahre alt sein aber er ist
halt ein schönes souvenir ist das jetzt
eine durchschnittsgröße oder ein kleiner
zahn oder kann ich mir so vorstellen so
ein ding hat quasi jeder gängige weiße
hai milliarden zahn oder weiß halt sagen
oder dass es eine durchschnittsgröße und
davon haben die haie natürlich einige
maul und 7
gezeigt dass wir haben also schöne säge
vorrichtungen und deswegen müssen hier
auch gar nicht so fest zubeißen man
denkt immer besser hätten den stärksten
bis alle tiere das haben sie aber gar
nicht nötig weil die zähne so scharf
sind also die beißen einfach nur in
einer robe oder in den war ein schütteln
den kopf ein bisschen hinterher und
trennen so große stücke fleisch ab aber
sie müssen eigentlich gar nicht so fest
zu weil die szene so perfekt geformt
sind
jetzt haben wir eingangs schon gesagt es
kommt immer wieder zu solchen hai
attacken und wir haben vor allen dingen
in den letzten monaten in den corona
monaten so viel über hai-attacken hier
berichtet ist das zufall oder passiert
das in der korona zeit tatsächlich
häufiger warum ja es ist wirklich
interessant also im letzten jahr gab es
insgesamt zwölf tödlicher hai angriffe
das ist schon ein kleiner rekord ich
glaube das letzte mal waren es 2013 so
viele
das ist natürlich eine vermutung dass
durch den wegfall der großen
frachtschiffe der motorboote die die
küste auf und ab fahren durch wasser ski
sportler durch jet ski sportler dass
sich die haie einfach trauen näher an
die küste und einen strand zu kommen und
auf der gleichen oder auf der anderen
seite besser gesagt die leute haben
nichts besseres zu tun als an den strand
zu gehen ins wasser zu gehen
sie können nicht einkaufen viele sind im
home office können auch nicht arbeiten
das heißt auf der einen seite haben wir
die haie die näher an die küste kommen
auf der anderen seite mehr menschen im
wasser jetzt gerade in australien des
sommer das heißt es sind sowieso viele
menschen im wasser und das steigert
natürlich das risiko eines angriffs also
könnte durchaus mit corona
zusammenhängen jetzt haben wir eben
gerade diese faszinierenden fotos von
dir gesehen wie du mit weißem hemd aus
was macht diese faszination aus es ging
mir durch den kopf als sie zwischen
diesen raubtieren im wasser war es warum
hast du das überhaupt getan und warum
hast du dich sehr sicher gefühlt
nun ich tauche mittlerweile seit 30
jahren und die faszination entstand als
kleiner junge so wie mein sohn jetzt
irgendwie dinosaurier mag hab ich damals
der weiße hai gesehen und hab dann mit
18 halten tauchschein gemacht aber nicht
weil ich unbedingt tauchen wollte
sondern weil ich sehen wollte und es war
einfach diese mischung aus furcht und
faszination dem ich immer ja gekitzelt
hat ich würde mir nicht als adrenalin
junkie bezeichnen
aber ich finde dieser raubtiere einfach
faszinierend
und ja bin ich gerne so nahe wie möglich
auch ohne käfig aber pass auf dich auf
christian wir brauchen dich hier vielen
dank an den bild kollegen und drei
experten christian kemper
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren